If you are looking for something to do as
your self socially distancing and physically
distancing and self isolating up, go to the
David Pakman show.
Read it at David Pakman dot com slash read
it rbd eiti.
Nearly nineteen thousand of our viewers and
listeners are now participating on our subreddit.
Some interesting posts I saw user restless
pedestrian posted an article about financier's
making a lot of money off of the pandemic.
I have been talking about this
more so on the livestreams than on the broadcast
show for a couple of weeks now.
There is a lot of money being made on coronavirus.
You have of course financiers and banksters
who are able now especially to start processing
these loans.
Under the paycheck protection plan, they get
five point 0 5 percent commission on every
dollar processed paid by the government.
You can rack up big profits doing that.
You've got the short sellers of different
kinds who at different points bet on the stock
market declining and made money off of that.
You have all sorts of different companies
jumping in and making masks and other things,
which of course is good.
Those things are needed, but they've proven
to be very profitable endeavors, including
when you get a slot speaking at a coronavirus
press conference like the My Pillow Trump
sycophant guy Michael Andell did
making some masks instead of pillows and getting
invited to speak on a national stage.
So there are all sorts of different people
that are cashing in on Corona virus.
And what we need to understand is this isn't
new.
Every tragedy, every calamity has a people
who are able to profit from it.
Sometimes people are profiting by helping
in a serious and sincere way.
Other times, people, they're taking advantages
of loopholes or vulnerabilities, scamming
people, selling things like, as you know,
silver toothpaste and others claiming they
killed a virus.
It is nothing new that there is plenty of
money to be made around tragedies.
And we are seeing that happen.
Another interesting discussion on the red.
It is black.
Ryan said we should start making a distinction
between the progressive left and the populist
left, pointing out that populism wants to
appeal to ordinary people who feel their concerns
are disregarded, whereas progressivism is
a particular political philosophy supporting
social reform and certain policy ideas.
I want to be careful about this for two reasons.
Number one, when we go crazy with how we name
different groups and categorize different
people, it's often not useful at all and is
often a distraction.
And you know, you if you've listened to some
of the pedantic phone calls, I will sometimes
get during live calls from people saying,
you know, I used to be a civil libertarian,
but now I am a moderate and cap or whatever
it is, it gets us very little.
It gets us very little in actually figuring
out how society, culture and the economy should
go.
So here's my one thought.
Populism can be left or right.
Populism in and of itself can can be left
or right.
And as the viewer is saying, we're distinguishing
between the progressive left and the populist
left.
I actually think that populist left implies
progressivism.
So for me, there's not really a conflict.
The populist left has elements of populism
with progressive social policy, progressive
economic policy, et cetera.
I would not overly focus on these labels.
Check out some of the work from the new schools.
Professor Federico Finkelstein, who is a fellow
Argentinean.
He's been a guest on the program.
Expert in populism, authoritarianism, et cetera.
Let's not go crazy with the labels and the
categorization.
I don't think we get much out of it.
Lastly, a bit of good news from the subreddit
User Bag of Squares has notified us that the
pandemic has resulted in their mom becoming
a fan
of the David Pakman show, pointing out that
she previously was a political sometimes with
some anti-Obama sentiment, but that she has
recently been on the online.
Media rabbit hole.
She came across The David Pakman Show and
now is a regular viewer of the show.
That's a good thing.
And I really I've heard a lot of those stories
actually during the pandemic.
A lot of people home and consuming media.
They wouldn't otherwise consume and really
great.
Appreciate it.
Say hi to your mom for me.
Join the discussion at David Pakman dot com
slash.
Read it.
It's free.
It's something to do.
And you'll see you'll see me on there.
You'll see producer Pat there.
Very, very exciting.